we had steve kahn the uh arizona general
manager on the show and uh hey how did
you
part of the recruiting of j.j watt what
did you do um
don do you have jj watts uh soundbite
from yesterday's press conference
uh ready cause he was asked you know
about the recruiting of him
and steve keim said that he he pulled
out all the stops
um blake shelton and frank caliendo and
this is how
j.j watt uh i give him credit they
attacked from all angles uh there was
i think steve and michael and everybody
did a great job of i mean there were
players there were coaches there were
um non-football people whatsoever that
reached out and were
in my ear and trying to convince me to
come down here and tell me all the great
things about it and
not only on the field but sending me
pictures of paradise valley and
everything off the field as well so
uh the recruiting pitch was strong and
heavy um but i
at the end of the day i just tell my
wife you know all signs just kind of
kept pointing back down here to arizona
and
and in my short time here on the ground
i can tell you that
i'm absolutely pleased and couldn't be
happier with my decision
so i guess um introducing non-football
person
uh frank caliendo back here on the rich
eisen show how are you frank
good and basically i've been called that
my entire career
if you if you have ever seen if you've
ever seen twitter after me doing a
sketch on tv
what's that guy doing out here he's a
non-football guy listen
i i want you to understand something
what people don't realize
yes is that with steve kyle i'm
basically like sharing stone in the muse
all right
[Laughter]
he turns
like every day i got a call from steve
time and he's like
this is a couple years ago he's like uh
hey
what do you think uh do you think we
stick with josh rosen i'm like no no
no no kyler murray is available you go
with that
you can trade him we'll figure out a
deal
and it just it all goes down um
i i i make things happen in the end
deandre hopkins
he says he's like do you think i should
absolutely you can pull one over on
bill o'brien easy and then i set this
all
up together i'm like here's what you do
i called my cap guy
and that was frank it was your idea it
was your idea to also see if uh
if if o'brien would take uh david
johnson in his contract right that was
your idea
absolutely right i i am an idea man
a lot of things that people a lot of
things that people don't think are
possible
so time tells me about this yesterday
it's like i got a text from him
i talked about you on the rich eyes like
oh okay
so i'm like what did you say he's like
uh he didn't really give anything he's
just vague he's like that you that i
that i helped recruit supposedly and uh
so i listened to it as many bags on me
as a flag football coach which by the
way
is 100 true i was terrible i was brutal
um gruden once he once texted gruden
during a game
and i was wearing this backpack as i was
coaching and groom's like is that a
bleeping backpack he's wearing while
he's coaching
get rid of this guy right now this guy
shouldn't be coaching your kid
so um all right so this is this is what
it really was
i think yes jj did his
uh jj i've known jj watt for
uh he's from wisconsin he grew up in
wisconsin right and i grew up
in waukesha wisconsin so we had that
kind of a tie he came out to shows
a show a year ago with his brothers we
snuck them in
believe it or not we snuck all three
watt brothers in which isn't easy
um and uh he was super cool super nice
and then they he when they when the pro
bowl was out here
uh my son went and met him and all sorts
of stuff so we kept in touch every once
in a while i'll text them something
about
uh you know how's the tommy bartlett's
robot world out there to wisconsin
dells or something like that right just
super nice guy
well i think this i think it was i said
the time uh
jj watts available you want to get them
no
no you're the muse so you should right i
mean let's see let's be honest it's a
complete
joke i'm joking i'm joking with time
he's like do it do it and like i can
feel time's beard coming through the
phone like do it do it
like ah and then i didn't and then he's
like then kind of just keeps coming at
me do it do it do you do it
i'm like all right so i text jj and i
like hey
uh time won't leave me alone okay um
he he loves you you know i'd be great
that you're here or something like that
i go
and you're probably already go and i i
did text this too i'm like you probably
already got
texts from deandre hopkins uh which mean
a lot
which you would mean a lot more and like
shelton uh
and he's like man he and he said the
same thing that he said in that press
conference texting me back you're coming
from all angles so super
mine was kind of mine was kind of a soft
sell i'm sure i had nothing really to do
with it i also
undersold it a little bit to be honest
with you because they knew and this was
already happening packer fans
are kicked off at me because i'm from
wisconsin yeah what are you doing paul
right what are you doing yeah listen
i can if if the team calls me i can help
but i can't help unless your nfl team
calls me
i have and there's a pecking order it's
gruden the packers
uh arizona i i gotta i gotta go through
life
you know you know what so so what you're
saying frank is brian guticun needs a
comic muse he doesn't have one
and look at him now yeah look at the
problems he's got you you know
and you if i am i am a helper when i i'm
here for people i don't
i don't even listen i don't do this
financially it does nothing for me i
don't make any money from this guy
exactly zero dollars for making things
happen
um so it was just so frank it was just a
text it wasn't a video or anything like
that he just
no no i texted time about that
too i was like he says when g when steve
said he probably frank probably
sent me that the jj a video of groot i'm
like yeah that would be a real good
sales point hey come out here to the
arizona cardinals where i'm not the
coach man
[Laughter]
i mean listen i would love to take i
would love to take
a responsibility for that but and i
thought
he is i got a text from the biggest
one of the biggest radio guys in the
morning radio guys in the country rover
he's like what did you do what did you
do in cleveland
he's like the browns fans are ticked and
like ah
steve's just trying to mess with me and
then i got a text from steve yesterday
your q rating is going out
for people who know that q rating it's
not whether people like you or hate you
it's just that they know who you are
that's right um i spell it right and
it's
it was 100 percent true but now i got
you know and i have to
i guess it's just so funny i think you
remember a couple years ago when i
completely supposedly destroyed the
draft by almost
john gruden calling steve time people
got that story wrong
but it's kind of funny i i think it was
pretty cool and it's it's great that uh
and they said he's gonna be out here and
they say you're a non-football and jj
calls you a non-football person please
come on you're [ __ ]
you know football frank you're a
football man yeah i
what did you want me to have sent them
like pictures of me work you know as a
spotter for him lifting weights and
stuff like that
five foot six 220 you're gonna
porky lift right here come on i can make
this happen
oh man well i wanted to get it straight
from you and i'm glad i did and uh
by the way uh last time chris i saw this
man was on a zoom square
uh he kicking us kicking off the bruce
aryan
family foundation yeah why wouldn't you
you were the first person i saw frank
when 10 minutes before where the zoom
begins we're in the green room
and and i look up and there's a couple
of the
the members of the production team that
are are there to
work us through the run of show and
there's
here is frank in the red sort of cap
of aryans and and a a glass
of what i was assuming was the real
stuff as opposed to like
uh you know like uh ginger ale or
whatever and then the real aryans
dressed the same way all in the same
sort of thing
and he had a
how do i get tom brady daddy i said
bruce
here i'm glad you came to me first of
all
you're the muse of temples
what do you think you think bruce you
think bruce arians called tom brady and
his english no no it's me
i get on the phone hey daddy what's
going on man listen you ever swim in a
swimming pool or crown royal i'll make
it happen daddy that's what it's all
about come on
you want to you want to win a super bowl
at 50. i can make it happen
i can make it happen we'll get it with
uh
what did lebron james do not five not
six nothing let's do that daddy is that
seven nine eight nine nine we're gonna
win ten super bowls yeah
just end up with these goggles glasses
jeff goldblum goggle glasses
and and uh some kind of a kingdom cap
that isn't a kango campus for my charity
man that's what we're doing
well here's a good line for you i'll
leave you with this frank since i'll
leave you in a better place
than uh then because you've left us in a
better place
so we had aries this is you can use this
line
we had aryans on our faces
on we had aryans on after they made the
super bowl right
we had him on after they beat green bay
a couple days later and i told him
hey you know because he told a story
about how he and his wife were driving
down to florida
after they parted ways with the steelers
and he thought like this was it and the
phone rang and it was
you know uh the indianapolis colts
calling him to say how about the job
it was chuck pagano and then i said like
if i had told you when you took that
phone call
that you would not only come back but do
what you did in indianapolis do what you
did in arizona and now you're the super
bowl
coach of tom brady what what would you
have said if i told you that was the
case and this is what he said what are
you smoking bro give me something that's
what he said
you're doing a tremendous job and i just
uh i wouldn't have believed it for the
last of me but it happened so uh 100
100 chance not about it no i did it
[Laughter]
all right frank you're the best thanks
for the call you'll be well sir sure
no problem i'm going to go help a couple
other nfl teams i've got some nba
people on my site uh mark mark cuban's
gone gotta go
oh you take care of yourself frank
thanks for the call
oh my god the one and only frank
caliando
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here